hey everyone this is Cameron with motion
science and I'm here today to show you a
workflow hack that I use on almost every
project that I work on when it comes to
being a slightly longer project or a
very render intensive project so for
this project this is one I just recently
finished up for the Cleveland Cavaliers
it's a project I was asked to freelance
on so this project is the actual
rendering section starts here finishes
here just over four like 407 frames it's
24 frames a second so that's what 16 17
seconds long I believe my math might be
off but anyways not too long of a
timeline but the actual rendering the
project is is somewhat intensive on the
effects and what it's doing so the
rendering takes quite a while to get
through so this hack is for rendering
projects when you're dealing with
clients which is all the time but a
client that has a quickly approaching
deadline and you're coming down to the
wire and you know that the project's 90%
there but there's that extra 10% that
the client is going to have last-minute
changes things that need to be done very
quickly at the last minute before the
project actually goes out the door
essentially I rendered that the sequence
out as one long long sequence and then I
fill in the blanks with last minute
tweaks that are requested by the client
how do I do that well I just go to my
sequence I go to composition add to
render queue my render queue has created
an output here my output module probably
looks different than yours this is one
that I've set up as a default but it
doesn't matter you just click on the
output module and instead of QuickTime
we want to render a PNG sequence we can
change things here like millions or
trillions of colors if you have an alpha
channel you can also do that as well
I don't have an alpha channel this is
only an 8-bit sequence so
I'm gonna leave that millions of colors
I'm gonna click okay I'm then gonna
click on this output to to set my PNG
sequence up and here I have my folder
structure set up I've created a folder
called PNG underscore seek seq for
sequence I'm gonna leave this is the
composition name these number signs
represent the frame numbers so when we
render out a PNG sequence if we're at
frame four zero seven four zero seven
will automatically be filled in here
zero zero four zero seven so I know what
frame it is hopefully that makes sense
I'll click Save and I'll just go over
here and click render and I'll be back
in a second okay so I'm back and the
render finished and what I'm gonna do
now is just to prep for a final render
is I'm going to import back into my
project the PNG sequence I just rendered
which is right here as you can see we
started at frame nine and ended at frame
four zero seven and like I said the
number signs equate to the frame numbers
here in the sequence so I know at any
time what frame I'm on here is frame 34
and so on so I'll select the first frame
I'll click on options to make sure that
PNG sequence is selected if it's not
selected when I click open it'll only
open the first image but by selecting
PNG sequence it's going to open the
entire sequence bring it into After
Effects and you can see here that it's
defaulted to 30 frames per second as I
mentioned previously the frame rate for
this is 24 frames a second so I'm going
to go to interpret footage main gonna
change it from 30 to 24 and then all I
have to do is just drag this sequence
into a new composition and boom here's
my entire sequence ready to go out the
door so now I've got a base render
completed so when my client comes back
to me with any last-minute changes in
the final hour
all I have to do is render specific
sections of the PNG sequence and they'll
update automatically here in the
sequence let me show you how I'm gonna
do that I'm gonna go back into my
composition here and let's say for this
particular part of the sequence but the
clients come back and I said hey you
know his name's not spelled right well
we know it's spelled right but for
demonstration purposes I'm gonna go
ahead and change his name and let's just
make it KYR why instead of ie
so we'll go into the composition here
I'm going to change it here make it a Y
and there we are back in the composition
so now all we have to do is render the
section from here let's say to here as
it goes away so I'll set my beginning of
main render points and you can see
they're here and let me show you a
little trick I have as well which is a
little hack I have as well which is
something it's called the background
renderer this is a plug-in you can get
from AE scripts column it's been around
for many many years it's an amazing
plugin I have used for as long as it's
been out what it does is it enables me
to click this button render what I need
to render but continue to work inside of
After Effects so if I just need to
update this little sequence right here
and then let's say I need to also update
this Nantz section and take the e off of
his name so I have two sections to
update well I want to go ahead and get
this section rendering since I've
already fixed it
so what I'm going to do is just go into
my background renderer I'm gonna click
background render it's gonna give me an
error that there's nothing in the render
queue I better go back to that set up a
PNG sequence
it's going to the same output so it's
just going to overwrite the sequence
specific to this change and I'll just go
back click background render again and
needs to save and boom there it goes I'm
on a Mac it's launched terminal terminal
is going to start this sequence
rendering and I think this only works on
a Mac so if you're on a PC sorry guys
but there you go see it started with
frame 46 it's gonna continue on you're
gonna see it's there's 46 where I
started it it's gonna end right here at
93 so now that's rendering while it's
rendering I need to go down here let's
just say I need to change this section
right here and boom boom boom I've made
my changes I'm ready to render this
section now so all I have to do is click
on render background etre again boom
it's gonna launch a second terminal
window you can see there's the first
render going and here's the second
render starting up and the great thing
about this is I can set up to eight of
these background render processes going
I've got an 8 core machine so it's gonna
go and I'm gonna continue to work away
and I'm gonna come back here in just a
minute
Oh actually before I do that let me show
you something cool about background
render as well under Advanced Settings
it's a simple plugin if you click
Advanced Settings all these other
options are gonna open up where it has
priority if it's a low medium or high
priority rendering I mean how much you
know the your processing power of your
computer it's gonna take the memory
usage
multi-processing this is the coolest
part to me post render actions if i
click configure and i open it up what
this does is I can tell background
renderer to notify me when the rendering
is done so if I need to set off a whole
bunch of renderers I can step away from
my computer and I know I'll get a
notification that hey your renders are
done come back
get back to work how I do that is I use
typically an SMS text alert or an iPhone
alert I'm telling it when the renderer
is done at the end I put in my phone
number here I'm with AT&T I say hey text
me a message click Save Settings I don't
have a phone I'm render someone had
canceled but awesome awesome feature
love it so let me go back really quick
to the terminal this first section is
now done and there you go the second
section has finished so the great thing
about this is I will go back into my PNG
sequence boom this is already updated it
was KYR ie now it's a Y if you notice
that the PNG sequence is not updating
all you have to do is go back to your
PNG sequence in the project window and
hit reload footage and it'll
automatically update for you so now I've
got all the changes made let's say that
this render wasn't originally an hour
long render well now it's gonna take
like two minutes to render because it's
a PNG sequence super quick all I have to
do is go to composition add to render
queue say it's a pro res 42 hit my
output boom hit render and there goes
the renders up the final sequence super
quick so that's what I got for you today
I hope you guys enjoyed the video leave
a comment below and let me know if you
learn something new in this video if you
already knew this or if there's
something else you want me to show you
guys how I work or tips and tricks for
you so let me know in the comments below
until next time I'm Cameron and this is
motion science